so I'll say again on camera like I've
been saying to you about 60 times you
made one of my favorite films of the
year I can't say enough positive things
everyone should go see it you can keep
going
okay the movies amazing up and ready to
put it in right risen forth but so last
night I got to do something I got to go
to your party last night and I want to
start with so if we can see and I'll put
it on the screen this is a photo of you
with Harrison Ford I I saw it wait was
there exactly so the thing that's
amazing about this photo is Harrison is
really happy and smiling and everyone is
asking me how did this happen I said it
was mangled it's not me Harrison isn't
he doesn't care about me I produced call
of the wild that he's into so that we've
got to know each other quite well
working on that and and I knew him
before that because we've often talked
about working together and we get along
but Harrison's a happy fellow he's not
he's not all darkness sure I think that
a lot of times he's like he comes across
like growly cos you know yes but like
yes but I have to ask you could you me
too
listen you've worked with some amazing
actors and you've always delivered these
amazing performances with people do you
with someone like Harrison who is
[ __ ] Harrison Ford do you sorry for
the language do you still get like that
thrill of oh my god it's Harrison Ford
or does it sort of not because you've
worked with such amazing people does it
sort of also get that thrill with all of
them it's just that it's honestly I
worked with Bob De Niro Vanessa Redgrave
Russel Crowe Christian Bale Matt Damon
Harrison Ford on and on Angelina Jolie
you get oh there's a moment where but
you can't meaning you can't go oh my god
I'm driving a Lamborghini and drive a
Lamborghini you have to actually drive
the car or you go off the road so
there's some point where you realize I
better direct this movie and stop
watching myself from a third eye
admiring Li me and that if that makes
any sense you have like it's either Here
I am I'm directing them in a movie I
can't sit here like a fan and watch
myself I have to get involved and do it
or else I'll make the worst movie sure
this actor ever made well I'm curious
the one was
time you were sitting across from
someone do you ever get like that
excitement is just a fan like you're not
working with them because like that's
Harrison Ford or that's does that still
hit you I'm always thrilled to meet
people who kind of have blown me away or
kind of been inspirations in my life and
Harrison certainly would be one of them
but then you you know I've spent weeks
and weeks and weeks hanging out with him
on sets so it's kind of I I get it one
of the things though so Matt's
performance and Kristin's performance in
this are both so spectacular and you
have had such spectacular performances
with some of your other films that
you've done with other people I'm
curious what is is there a common
element with all these actors that you
sort of noticed that makes them who they
are do you don't I mean like is there
it's like well there's several different
things one is I mean I thank you for
small it's very kind in terms of the
quality of the performances I I try hard
to create an environment where that
happens and there's several different
things you can do to make that happen in
my opinion one is recognize that actors
aren't professional liars they're
professional truth tellers and what I
mean by that is that if you look at
acting as lying then you're missing the
whole point
acting they have to become it and they
have to believe it and they have to make
people even looking at them from six
inches away with a gigantic lens believe
it and in order to do that they become
experts in being truthful it's really
feeling it and therefore they're also
experts in [ __ ] and what I mean by
that is that most movie stars live in a
world of people telling them you're so
awesome that was so great even when they
know it wasn't great all the time you're
so great you did that so great your joke
was so funny and they know even though
they act like they love it they know
when they're getting [ __ ]
and I think most great actors I've ever
worked with like the straight dope
sometimes it disappoints them sometimes
it's not what they want to hear but in
the long run they want to have something
real they want
director to be real and awake and
looking out even the greatest actors in
the world have bad takes even the
greatest actors in the world sometimes
go off on a tangent in a scene someone
better be there in my position to corral
it and they're grateful when you are
because it's like you can't have a
football team without a coach
it's all part of it and so that is one
thing I mean in that Bob De Niro taught
me a long time to go on Copland when he
I was a young director and he he said to
me I want to be directed don't be shy
just because I'm Bob De Niro I want to
know what you think I want to give you
what you want and that gift to me back
when I was thirty with him was the
realization that even the greatest among
them loves the collaboration with the
director and he gives you permission to
tell them the truth and be honest with
them and push them as hard as you can
sure there is a scene where a not meant
doing spoilers but there's a fun fight
scene if you will between a mat and
Christian where Christians come back
from getting groceries and when you see
these two actors you're normally seeing
them in these big movies where they're
kicking so much ass and they're
indestructible but at least two guys
just who love each other but are mad at
each other what is it like sort of
filming that kind of a fight scene where
you're trying to make it as realistic as
possible well it was actually the thrill
of both guys were so into it the thrill
was to make times they called it their
pathetic fight sequence but the but what
they really felt about it was a
realistic one meaning that both of these
actors have participated in countless
hyper choreographed fight sequences and
have come to the point where they
probably recognize the inherent artifice
in them and that the joy of making what
actually two guys really look like when
they're bruising around on each other
trying in the way that many fights are
people really don't want to kill each
other they're somehow just taking out a
[ __ ] love or aggression on each other as
brothers often do or friends and that
that was what they're trying to capture
the kind of fraternal brawl sure it
works that's good
one of my favorite scenes in the film
and I don't want to spoil the specifics
but it involves Tracy and Matt driving
and how can I say this without ruining
anything but they're on a drive on the
track and I think you could say that
that Matt takes Tracy's which Carroll
Shelby takes takes henry ford ii for a
bit of a wild ride yes that's the best
way to say talk a little bit while
filming that scene and the the way you
film it at the end because i mean it
brings the house down it's such a great
scene yeah well thank you it was that
well it's it really credit is to Tracy
Letts and Matt Damon I mean I put them
in a car and we was on the biscuit rig
so they didn't actually have to drive
but someone was driving from up above
and put them in a sin and put drove them
at high speed through a slalom and then
spun out on a dime and they did the
scene live with the cameras connected to
the car so it's all just one take of
that scene
yeah I got to stop there I'm just gonna
say that when people see it it's Tracy's
so awesome in that scene Tracy's great
the acting in this movie and the actors
are top-notch I mean you have a cast
with Jon Bernthal and Josh Lucas and
Katrina both on and on where any one of
them would be the lead in a lot of
movies and they're all they're all
happily part of this ensemble and great